[Music]
what I'm dying to ask you is related to
nervousness I've had a number of
interviews and episodes where I've
really been nervous for different
reasons and that has led me to prepare
in different ways and respond in
different ways are there any interviews
that come to mind over your career that
you're particularly nervous about before
him yeah I mean I think throughout my
career obviously dignitaries heads of
state I remember I interview Yasser
Arafat I was very nervous about that
Ross Perot was very pugnacious and kind
of ornery and you never knew what he was
gonna do I think you know live
interviews are really scary
yeah because you can't you know edit
things out you can't ask a question over
again in a more eloquent way and you're
really on the spot so I think live
interviews would make me nervous
I remember I was supposed to interview
with Tom Brokaw OJ Simpson after he was
acquitted and I was a nervous wreck at
the very thought of it because I thought
first of all I'm not a prosecutor mm-hmm
I my husband who had passed away later
but who was alive and covering a lot of
the OJ trial knew everything he was a
criminal defense white-collar criminal
defense lawyer and I just remember
thinking that this is just a no-win
situation first of all I can't retry the
case nor could I because I don't really
have the talent or the skills to do that
and secondly it was so divisive and
polarizing that whole situation and so
racially charged and I at the time and
still do to a certain extent just hated
like people attacking me and I thought
it was just a no-win situation so when
he bailed I wanted to do a happy dance I
was so excited so you know situations
like that would make me extremely
nervous when I saw so much risk and
so much downside and very little upside
right but but I think whenever I'm
interviewing people who are really smart
and really knowledgeable about a certain
area and I don't know nearly as much as
they do that can be hard and I think
also when you're interviewing somebody
about a wide range of public policy and
you're not you're not necessarily a
policy wonk that's challenging to but
you know to go to the White House and
interview a president either live or
even on tape is really stressful
interviewing Sarah Palin when I
interviewed her because I thought it was
so important to strike the right tone
ask the right questions and it was a
very critical time I think to understand
her motivations and actually her
abilities so I still get nervous when I
have big interviews
you